[Music]
country star Chris Lane has popped the
question to his now fiancee former
bachelor star Lauren Bushnell that a
year the romantic proposal in Laurens
parents backyard isn't the only thing
that has people buzzing we got to talk
about that stunning ring I feel like
we're so happy it'll be an exciting time
for sure to help us break it all down we
went to an expert
Catherine money from brilliant earth to
get the deets on the diamond Catherine
says it's an emerald cut three and a
half carat diamond set on a delicate
diamond accented band the simple yet
elegant design makes it easy to keep the
focus on that gorgeous center stone the
cost Catherine says it's somewhere
between 60 and 80 thousand dollars
the reality star isn't the only one
rocking an emerald cut sparkler she's in
good company with Jennifer Lopez and
Jennifer Lawrence who both recently got
engaged and opted for the same shape
Catherine points out that emerald cuts
are growing in popularity and we can see
why the elongated style of diamond
creates a flattering look that appears
to lengthen your finger the engagement
is Lauren's second the first was in 2016
when she won Ben Higgins season of The
Bachelor
[Music]
then proposed with the biggest ring in
bachelor franchise history at the time a
4.25 carat Art Deco style ring with a
radiant cut center stone surrounded by
round and baguette cut diamonds our
diamond expert says Lauren's ring from
Chris is more contemporary and
understated which perfectly complements
her down-to-earth personality here's
what she told ET just weeks before Chris
popped the big question
she's already warned me if if I ever
propose to never do it in a public to be
private or a little more private than
out of show you know it's coming on I
mean I I hope at the end of the day I
feel like we're so happy I'm not
necessarily looking for that next step
to change anything it's just yeah it'll
be an exciting time for sure it'll
definitely happen at some point
Chris you did well man
[Music]
and she although I got some big big
plans
[Music]